[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARJITA SETHI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome back to Public Speaking
Pro Tips with Speechless,
presented by Google Developers.
We help people turn the
mundane into memorable.
CLAIRE SLATTERY:
Challenges into insights.
ARJITA SETHI: And presentations
into performances.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And we
do that with something we
call improv thinking.
Let's jump into today's tip.
Get ready to fall in love.
ARJITA SETHI: What?
But I'm already married.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: No, no, no.
Not that kind of love.
The kind of love
I'm talking about
is the love that
can only be shared
between a presenter and her
favorite spot in the room.
ARJITA SETHI: How romantic.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: This exercise
is called I Love My Spot,
and it's a great
way for presenters
to get comfortable in the venue
before they take the stage.
ARJITA SETHI: I love this game.
It always helps settle
my nerves to play this
before a big presentation.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Exactly.
So let's play and show
them how it's done.
First, walk around the room,
and find a spot that feels good.
And you can be picky.
Remember, you need
to fall in love.
ARJITA SETHI: Found it.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Great.
Now repeat this simple phrase.
I love my spot.
ARJITA SETHI: I love my spot?
CLAIRE SLATTERY: I love my spot.
ARJITA SETHI: I love my spot.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Great.
So now once you've
found your spot,
really own it, and tell
me what you love about it.
So Arjita, why is
your spot so great?
ARJITA SETHI: I love my
spot, because the lighting
is great from here.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Yeah, it is.
And any other reasons?
ARJITA SETHI: I love
my spot, because this
is the spot from where
I'm going to give the most
important talk of my life.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Wow.
That is the best
reason I've ever heard.
ARJITA SETHI: Thanks.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Well, I hate
to break it to you, Arjita,
but you're going to need to
find another spot to love.
ARJITA SETHI:
Claire, I couldn't.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: You must.
ARJITA SETHI: Fine.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: So yeah.
Just mill about the space.
Find another spot
that feels good.
ARJITA SETHI: OK.
Found it.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: I love my spot.
ARJITA SETHI: I love my spot.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Well, great.
Why?
ARJITA SETHI: Well,
it's just brought me
closer to my audience.
I can connect to them more.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: Great.
Which spot do you love more?
ARJITA SETHI: I think
I love this one better.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: All right.
Now it's your turn.
Go ahead and make a
video about a space
that you have to speak
from and why you love it.
This will help
you take ownership
of the space and
your talk, leading
to a more confident and
grounded presentation.
ARJITA SETHI: Take
your video, and post it
to Social with the
hashtag, #DevelopYourVoice.
CLAIRE SLATTERY: And remember,
check the description
below for links from Google
Developers, Women Techmakers,
and more tips from
Speechless and how
to think like an improviser
and develop your voice.
[MUSIC PLAYING]